hey youtubers is Charlie this is gonna
be my Gotham episode a video probably
one of the best episodes in a long time
for several different characters there's
a bunch of other huge stuff that
happened this morning so I'm gonna do
news at the end of this so here we go
just careful for spoilers if you haven't
seen this episode of Gotham yet starting
with top 5 WTF the penguin meets the
Riddler this is gonna be so much fun
both of the characters have embraced
their craziness the Riddler seems a
little more well adjusted than the
penguin just because the penguin is
frothing at the mouth to kill Pheo
but then running into each other is
straight out of a grim fairy tale who is
afraid of the big bad penguin somebody
stole my sandwich and there's just a
trail of blood leading away also can we
just talk about how awesome this set
decoration is just like look at the car
that the Riddler is driving in the
costume that he's wearing that actually
reminds me of something the Scarecrow
wore during Batman the Animated Series
but someone actually asked me like
what's gonna happen now that the Riddler
is meeting the penguin I mean obviously
they're gonna work together but my joke
answer was many many fanfics are going
to happen I'd really like for it to turn
into this Hannibal situation but that's
not necessarily the relationship that
will and Hannibal shared during that
series even if you don't know what that
means make sure to check out Hannibal at
some point they've already cancelled the
series there's only three seasons but it
is awesome on the number 4 though
speaking of Hannibal they have to do
something with those two bodies like
they still have to finish burying the
bodies when the Riddler turned around
and noticed that his sandwich was gone
he seems so preoccupied by the idea that
he just walked off following that trail
so the hunters body and Miz kringles are
still lying in that open grave they have
to fix that now because when the penguin
came stumbling out it looked like he was
on the edge of death they're probably
gonna address that first like the
Riddler will probably patch him up he
has rudimentary medical skills but I
feel like there's a lot of potential in
that pairing like I feel like that's
gonna make for some really awesome TV
some really awesome scenes together
because the penguin is just completely
over the edge he's a totally dark
character and the Riddler just accepted
his dark self I was a man with two
selves at war with each other you helped
me fix that Miss Kringle thank you
more crazy on to number three Bruce is
tempted to sign away Wayne Enterprises
to Theo to find out who killed his
mother I feel like we're all thinking
the same thing Theo probably either did
it himself or higher
the person to do it the question is is
who actually pulled the trigger in most
tellings of the Batman origin story it
ends up being Joe Chill so theo probably
hired Joe Chill I do like how they
dodged the reveal I feel like it would
have been kind of disingenuous for Bruce
to find out who killed his parents when
he was really young part of what drives
Batman is the rage over not knowing what
happened even after he becomes Batman
for a little while he still doesn't know
it just it's all fuel for the Batman
fire but I do like that they didn't go
Dark Knight Rises route where the
company just goes to complete [ __ ] and
Bruce has to get it back he's just he's
way too young for that storyline and
that's not really an interesting
storyline for a child actor Bruce's
storylines tend to be a little more
interesting when they're tied up with
Catwoman storylines so hopefully they'll
dive down this silver st. cloud rabbit
hole with Catwoman
Bruce versus Theo is interesting but
Bruce versus silver I think is going to
be a little bit more fun on the number
two though Barbara and Gordon try to
out-crazy each other this is so much fun
just that the early part of the police
station where Gordon seems like he's
completely drunk the kool-aid I have
feelings for you too like for a minute I
was actually fairly surprised like
what's what's going on here and until
the reveal we just played along so we
can find out what's going on with Bo
but then Barbara pulls a fast one when
they get to the place where she wants to
go so it's Gordon seeing her crazy
trying to one-up her and then her just
completely one-upping him trying to
one-up her crazy on top of crazy on top
of crazy
now obviously Barbara isn't the Joker
character but most of you may have
gotten a Michael Keaton Batman vibe when
they went to the Cathedral the end of
the first Michael Keaton Batman film
where they chase each other like all the
way up to the top of the bell tower in
this case it was wedding bells but you
get the idea like thematically they're
just trying to invoke a lot of that
imagery whether you love or hate the
Barbara character I feel like these are
some of the best scenes that she's been
in all season they have it out to their
logical conclusion and Barbara seemingly
commits suicide she lets go and just
falls into the abyss of the bushes below
I don't feel like she was trying to
escape I felt like she was just like
okay I'm done I'm out peace but finally
on to my number one WTF moment Barbara
is not dead she's not gone she just
broke herself with that fall and she
broke Lea in Gordon's relationship when
Lea was like hey you know after this is
all over
we need to talk the talk is going to be
we need to break up Lee is a total
trooper putting up with all this stuff
but she just she immediately recognizes
that Gordon is just as crazy as Barbara
in a different direction Gordon is crazy
like Batman is crazy you see a fire you
see a disaster you have to run to it
like Batman is every bit as
psychologically damaged as most of the
criminals that he goes after it's just
like when you talk about alcoholics
there are alcoholics and then there are
functional alcoholics like he's able to
make it work for him Gordon is able to
make his crazy work for his profession
so you're just not quite as able to
recognize it like when it's covered in a
cape and cowl but make no mistake we are
not gonna see Gordon in any kind of
therapy but I am interested to see if
Hugo Strange steps in did because he is
such a psychological character he might
start working with Barbara and they have
casts you go strange for the show he is
coming on they haven't said which
episode he's gonna debut in but like we
have Victor fries is coming on the show
there's just there's a couple more big
Batman villains coming along so you guys
can let me know like what was your
favorite part of this episode and do you
feel like this you know of all of
Barbara's episodes do you feel like this
is the best I feel like even if you hate
her character this was actually a good
episode for her character but that's
just the beginning there's like there's
so much other stuff that happened today
so here's like a breakdown of the stuff
that I'm gonna be working on next so we
have the flash season 2 tonight that's
enter zoom we're gonna get a whole lot
of zoom so I'm gonna do that video next
there's a new Jessica Jones trailer I'm
gonna do a video for that after I do my
flash video obviously there's agents of
shield so I'll do that too but we also
found out that Jeffrey Dean Morgan is
supposed to be negan on The Walking Dead
no big deal just see how many f-bombs
you can drop in the span of a minute be
sure to subscribe to get all that stuff
and I will be posting updates on like
what you know when videos are coming on
Facebook and Twitter the links for that
or at the bottom of the description I'm
actually really excited I always love
when I wake up and there's like five
videos that I need to make that I didn't
realize that needs to make the night
before it just means there's a lot of
exciting stuff happening so what you
guys wait for everything you can click
here for the flash trailer for the
episode that's coming tonight and you
can click here for last night's Game of
Thrones white Walker video that I posted
thank you so much for watching everybody
let's high five I'll see you guys
tonight
you